hey so smart and I decided to change the
title a little bit to pick up your
workflow how do we get to understand how
programs work one way is to just read
the code top to bottom read all the
files executed in your head remember all
the variables argument names keep
stackin mind well it might work for
small projects but when you have
something big it would take a while say
imagine you're joining project has
hundreds of JavaScript files and the
hundred thousand lines of JavaScript
code are you going to read all of that
before you start working on some feature
or fixing bug how do you even start the
project is so big you don't know which
file do you need one way of
understanding how program work is
inserting console.log statements
everywhere so you open your editor you
find some function you put some
console.log statements you open the
browser you reload the page see what's
in the console if it's not what you
expected the e do the same over again
another way is to use the bugger and in
some break points
breakpoints are great because you can
insert them without reloading the page
and you can disable them too but one
problem with breakpoints is that they
block so imagine your dragon race
condition and you have two functions
competing and when you step on a break
point it just blocks the execution and
breakpoints really not the best tool for
that kind of task so today I'm going to
be showing few other tools that I
believe not so popular and I think they
are great for understanding how programs
run and how they work and they actually
allow you to see on actual state of the
program so the first one is a light
table one cool feature that i like is in
line Watchers when we read the code we
don't really know what's inside the
variable and light table allows to watch
to select some code and start watching
it and it will show the value in real
time as the program round so I'm gonna
run some demo on the right side side
there's an there's a t5 Jay has demo
it's a processing library and JavaScript
and the on let's out there's a code and
I see the variables but I don't know
what they are what is either is it visit
some number well it's undefined on first
click and and some object on a second
click and you can see lifetime was
updating in real time here's some
velocity property I don't know what it
is oh it's a vector and it updates in
real-time as you play around with your
code
there's some drag property I don't know
what that is Oh some member
so that was um watch salam o it was it
watch expression another culture tool is
in-line evolved so it works like this
you just select some code and press
command enter and it shows the last
value right in the code not somewhere in
the console but right there so those
were two features of flight tabled I
really like and I think even if you
don't use light table maybe you should
check it out and if you work on some dev
tools maybe should implement some of
those features in I your favorite tool
timeline timeline is own timeline is
available in chrome devtools Firefox dev
tools WebKit inspector and when people
talk about timeline they usually talk
about profiling performance measurements
I'm gonna use it a little bit different
so here's a demo
it's the same webpage it's during
timeline to record the events so I want
to know I want to find the function that
is responsible for Mao Stalin events or
click and I don't know where it is I
don't know how many files i have but i
could see all the JavaScript events all
the timers all mouse events so there are
way too many so I just filter down to
mouse
from there I can jump right to the
function that was executed on mouse down
and I didn't read any code before that
so this is a good tool to give you
overview of how your program work when
you see a program for first time you
don't know where to start you just you
can play around and see what's get
executed but from there you can jump to
the files and functions that you
actually want to edit
so another tool is uh adobe brackets
Theseus so it's actually an extension to
other be brackets which is a JavaScript
I'm sorry which is a code error so I'm
going to play another demo
I have a game so it's just web page with
some JavaScript
and in the editor you can see there
there are some 21 calls 22 calls 23
calls 24 calls so this is actually log
in all the function calls that are
happening on the webpage you can
actually see what is running this time
you can see which functions are not used
and which ones are used and you can
narrow down you can see all the all the
function names and you can see the
arguments they're all there you don't
need to insert hundreds of console logs
from there you can see that from
keyboard input manager all those
callbacks were called and you can see um
call stack and you can go up
oops
ok
so that was a bit brackets disease
another similar tool is available in the
webstore webstorm is a ID and then it
has a feature called spy jas it is
somewhat similar to the brackets it
teaches but it has slightly different
user interface i'm going to show you
what would where am I
hmm maybe not
um maybe I'm not gonna show you it okay
so ignore that
so it logs all the events on the Left
column and speed it up a little bit
it highlights is a light green
background the piece pieces of code that
actually ran so you can see there's the
conditional here and that you can see
that didn't run because it doesn't have
a background you can actually see which
parts got executed there are lots of
events there
same as in under the brackets you can
see argument values
that was webstorm spy jazz
so well I think it's all cool but when I
wouldn't be even better I think what if
i just could play it back so oops
ok
so about one year at one year and a half
ago I was playing around with that one
tool and I call the dumbarton rewind so
say I do some dumb operations I don't
want to change attribute and what if I
just played back and forward and back
and so I was working on a tool that
captures all the Dom manipulations
stores them and allows to rewind them
eventually I realized it's not really
practical because I only capture Dom I I
don't capture JavaScript events I don't
capture input say if there's some
something going on in set interval and
it tries to access the dome and I rewind
it it just it will try to do something
with the element that is no longer there
so it generally work out and I just kept
it as a unperceived project so hopefully
fortunately there are some other two
tools out here so this is this is a
timeline again in our webcam inspector
and I'm running working nightly I have a
have a hidden feature it's called web we
play at this stage it's doesn't do that
much what you'll see
so I basically played back as it was it
captured all the user input all the non
deterministic values such as math.random
or any time related information and
place exactly the same as it was
for now it's a all it does but wouldn't
be amazing if you can just rewind back
edit some code play it back maybe it
even a loop some part so maybe a loop
some animation and took around with
values and it would just play and you
don't need to hit refresh all the time
so this was a current implementation in
the WebKit nightly and I'd like to
finish with them a video
users frequently encounter bugs and web
applications but don't report them
because it's difficult to write down
reproduction steps our programs inputs
are often difficult to enumerate for
example this video games behavior is
determined by user input random numbers
and social media API queries time-lapse
is an integrated debugging tool that can
precisely capture reproduce entire
program executions to record a user
opens the time-lapse tour and starts and
stops recording by clicking a button
instead of writing reproduction steps
users can record an execution while they
demonstrate interactive behaviors and
interests recordings can be saved to or
loaded from file and shared by email or
bug tracking software recordings can be
replayed on demand using timelapses
navigation avoidances time-lapse
visualizes program inputs over time
using several linked views that provide
different levels of detail an overview
shows the entire recording and its
inputs using a stacked line graph each
input category is visualized with the
heatmap timeline users can adjust the
displayed interval by adjusting zoom
settings with link sliders or by
scrolling horizontally and vertically
each circle can be inspected to reveal
the inputs it represents lower level
recording details are also available the
current replay position can be changed
by dragging the red slider in any view
while by double-clicking an input circle
there's nothing mazing that you can well
I hope at some point you'll be able to
just rewind back and play it again and
if it doesn't work changed in value
playback all we do we basically hit
refresh all day long and I think it's
not necessary time lapse is not only
it's now called web replay and it
doesn't yet allow you to rewind as I
showed you but
I hope we'll get there eventually I hope
web replay will change the way we
develop web apps thank you